he's back islamic state releases a video
of what it says is its leader
abu bakr al-baghdadi appearing for the
first time in five years
the propaganda video released on monday
says the islamic state has been defeated
in syria
referring to the final battle in the
city of bagooz but
that the war against what it sees as the
christian west and its allies
is far from over
the battle between islam and its people
and in it the barbarity and savagery
of the nation of the cross towards islam
was clear
he promises to seek revenge for the
killing and imprisonment of its fighters
in syria
and praises the deadly attacks in sri
lanka on easter sunday
which killed 250 people as well as a
spate of smaller attacks around the
world
despite a 25 million us dollar bounty on
his head
he's alive and he says he's still in
charge he looks humbled
and much older than five years ago
it's a far cry from this moment the
establishment of the islamic state's
caliphate
announced from the pulpit of nori mosque
in mosul iraq in 2014
al-baghdadi is saying that although
islamic state may not be powerful in
syria
it's still internationally active and
paying close attention to world events
marcus kime joins us now he's from the
german institute for international
and security affairs good morning marcus
great to have you
on again um assuming this video is
indeed authentic what's its message i
think the key messages
uh or the key message is a threefold one
the first
key message is i'm alive
with couple of reports about baghdadi's
death over the last couple of years so
he can now prove that he's alive the
second message is
he's in charge he's the sole authority
to run the operations of the islamic
state
and the third key message maybe is the
important most important one
and the fight will continue in a
different form okay now
where might he be uh is has virtually no
territory
left rubble basically in syria where
might he be located and could he be
running
his network from hiding to be honest we
have no idea and we have no indications
from the
video where he is it might be
afghanistan it might be the philippines
it might be some other place
but i think it doesn't really matter
because he does not really
run the logistics of terrorist
operations of the islamic state
he's running a web of affiliates
which he inspires and he can continue to
do so
from every hideout in the world okay you
say that he
inspires so his function at this point
is primarily inspirational then for
is members and and people want to be
members around the world
absolutely and that illustrates how is
has changed
from the from a terrorist organization
in 2014
into a political military organization
for the last couple of years and now
it's returning back to a terrorist
organization
inspiring islamists all around the world
what about the timing of this video we
haven't heard from them there have been
audio
uh recordings absolutely um but we
haven't seen him for
for five years can you tell us something
about the timing i think it's crucial
here because it uh
over the last year a month we heard all
we almost all exclusively discussed the
decline of islamic state the defeat the
military defeat of the islamic state
and given this environment or changing
environment it's it's
crucial for the islamic state to prove
that he
he is alive and that the islamic state
as organization
is capable of continuing continuing the
fight
you mentioned the word war of attrition
uh which
is the future of this kind of fight
okay the future of this kind of fight
can we expect more is attacks on on
soft targets including here in europe
i'm afraid so maybe not so much in
western europe because western
intelligence services
are very have have
continued to fight against the islamic
state but we have seen
a spread of islamic state in other areas
of the world you mentioned the
philippines
where the tremendous spread of the
islamic star stayed in afghanistan and i
think we
will see a continual continuation of
further attacks
mark this time from the german institute
for international security affairs thank
you so very much for
the insights